bottom line is we're only two weeks and
two days away from the regular season
debut for the cowboys at home against
the giants no sign of ezekiel elliott
and chris i do three days a week or
thereabouts the pftpm podcast in the
afternoon and it is free form no breaks
i babble about whatever i want to babble
about answer a lot of questions and
every once in a while i'll have like a
brainstorm while i'm in the process of
articulating my feeble thoughts and the
idea i had yesterday it all fell
together for me i want you to to chime
in on whether or not you think this
holds any water but i think at the core
here the cowboys are trying
to force upon their roster the patriot
way yeah they don't like the fact that
bob kraft has found a way to hold
together a great team
by having guys who will happily take
less
and jerry jones and stephen jones are
trying their damnedest to convince their
guys to take
less that they want that same dynamic
and they can't make it happen and it's
driving them bonkers trying to make that
happen with guys like dak prescott
ezekiel and amari cooper your thoughts
yeah i don't think you're wrong there i
mean first off everybody should be
aspiring to be like the new england
patriots i mean i mean come on the
proof's in the pudding but the big thing
is it's hard to do that there's a few
things where i look at where i go oh
this is where the cowboys differ from
the new england patriots first off the
cowboys build up their stars right i
mean they do they gush about him you
hear oh he's the the straw that stirs
our drink jerry jones has a press
conference after every game and tells
everybody how great amari cooper is and
how great dak prescott is robert kraft's
not doing that bill belichick doesn't
let his team or his players talk about
other players and how well they're
playing he'll give them who made you the
guy that gives the state of the union
address speech if you do that and that
doesn't go on in dallas either and the
last thing i think that is very
important to what the difference is it's
hard to do it the patriot way the
patriot way is special because bill
belichick finds players that he values a
specific skill set or something about
them and the rest of the league doesn't
quite see the value that he sees and
he's able to
maybe get guys right that everybody else
looks at and goes oh that's a six
rounder that's a seventh rounder and
bill goes well yeah okay you know maybe
it is but he can work on my football
team how many years do we see them trade
down in the draft do things like that so
i think that's the fundamental
difference but i do agree with you that
i do think they're trying to kind of
pull that off and maybe start to draw
the line in the sand that way
and also the patriots have a knack for
finding guys who are more inclined to
take less yeah part of that makeup and
there's a certain element of gratitude
when you're the guy who sees something
in a julian element that no one else saw
when you see what teddy brewski can
become when all throughout the course of
the last 18 years they've been blessed
by guys who are worth far more than what
they're getting but who are happy to
take less this isn't begrudgingly taking
less they have a locker room full of
guys who are happy to take less starting
with quarterback tom brady the cowboys
don't have that chris and you know the
point about constantly providing the
over top assessment about how great your
guys are that does set you up to have to
pay them right i mean when they traded
for amari cooper and they boasted about
amari cooper and mark cooper ended up
being better with the cowboys and he was
with the raiders the end result is
you're gonna have to pay him more money
now yeah to to you you're setting
yourself up for it so you know unless
and until the cowboys want to behave
like the patriots organization behaves
they're not going to find a locker room
full of guys who are willing to take
less so what they're going to have to do
they got two choices then you you either
pay all your stars and you get by with
what you can as backups like the vikings
have tried to do by paying market value
to a bunch of different guys and having
nothing behind them or you just make
tough decisions like the seahawks have
done right you let guys go and then you
hope that you can backfill with someone
cheaper who you have the faith that
you've scouted them you've developed
them and they're ready to go but those
are your choices it can be done if
you're willing to go with very thin
depth but you know the cowboys want to
still try to force these guys into
becoming like patriots players and it's
just not going to work no it's not and
you know as you mentioned as i mentioned
they kind of embolden these guys from
the get-go when they get there in dallas
and hey you got to take over you're our
star ezekiel elliott you're the fourth
pick in the draft all those things to
where yeah they build them up that way
also i think the patriots and what they
do you know to your point about like the
julian edelman and guys that take less
they're great at not only the physical
evaluation but the psychological
evaluation the tests they give out the
due diligence their scouting staff does
in their little area to really dig in to
find what makes this guy right i mean is
this guy a weight room guy is he a yes
sir coach i'll do whatever you say coach
is he willing to just do whatever it
takes for the team new england scouting
department does things like that where
it separates them from the rest of the
league as well to find those type of
guys those little diamonds uh in the
rough per se so that all plays into it
mike along with your points uh you're
exactly right and there's a style of
play that's different you know new
england looks to be
on defense they play a 3-4 scheme to it
a little bit which means like they
basically hold guys up and read and
react and that's why guys like trey
flowers don't get 15 and 16 sacks a year
when they're in new england it's a
little bit more of a read and react
system where dallas they play attack
attack so then they go after some super
freaks at times to just go hey we need
this guy to attack and take over and
because of that uh those guys demand
more money too because their stats look
a lot more sexy and their highlights
look a lot more sexy and that demands
more money too
and and i really do think that that the
inability of the cowboys to talk these
guys into happily taking less is causing
them to just not know how to get out of
this maze and i think it's one of the
reasons why stephen jones the ceo of the
team said earlier this week that the
agents aren't really thinking about the
long-term interest no because
the agents want to get the guys paid as
much as they can but the guys want to
get paid too dak prescott said earlier
this year when he was asked about taking
less like tom brady nobody's wife makes
as much money as tom brady's wife does
when tom brady isn't the breadwinner in
the home then that's a great problem to
have the message was clear he's not
doing a hometown discount he's not doing
a team-friendly deal chris when you
brought that up to him while the two of
you were sitting on a mattress right at
super bowl 53. he gave you the side eye
he did he was like he's not he's not
going for that you know you don't strike
me as a selfish guy you'll do a
team-friendly deal he was like watch it
there yeah mr top button he was he was
like i'll knock you out and
i want my money definitely
but the you know you're exactly right uh
from that standpoint
and you know watching the game last
night right troy aikman i'm watching the
the jags dolphins game troy aikman and
joe buck around there they got into some
of that dallas cowboy stuff towards the
end of the fourth quarter and troy
aikman even said who we know troy loves
the cowboys and the jones family he said
if he was zeke elliott's agent he would
be advising him to do the very exact
same thing he's doing right now and i
think that says a lot they're in a tough
spot and i really still think this is a
team
that is a super bowl caliber football
team
but they've built the team around their
o-line and their run game and the runner
they have is special and man they're
blowing they're gonna blow a chance to
maybe set themselves up for a super bowl
if they don't get ezekiel in there now
and just why can't i mean if they just
one-up todd gurley a little bit i wonder
if zeke elliott would be like okay
that's good uh i i wonder if he would
take that but right now it sounds like
it's between le'veon bell and between
todd gurley's contract and he's going
wait i've outperformed those two guys
the last three years and i haven't been
hurt i didn't sit out a year i've led
the league in rushing to it in the last
three years and i'm the guy that's
beaten the crap out of my body with 25
to 30 carries a game and oh yeah another
70-something receptions in the past game
so he has every right to do what he's
doing hold strong zeke elliott
yeah strange dilemma for the cowboys on
one hand they've got the cannon loaded
if they can get everyone on the same
page for a super bowl run in 2019 but i
feel like they're starting to get a
little greedy and they're thinking they
can turn the clock back to 1992 through
1995 and keep these guys together and
have a team that can maybe win two or
three not just one
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports